good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you're joining us
from welcome to simply learn we're
honored to have you join us today for
aligning ITIL service continuity and
cloud computing five keys to success
with your host Manuel Lloyd my name is
Richard and after a century we'll be
mostly in the background helping manual
so that everything goes smooth and then
I'll come back in for the last 15
minutes for the Q&A period aligning ITIL
service continuity with cloud computing
five ways keys to success idle
information technology infrastructure
library a library of practices for IT
Service Management that focuses on
aligning the IT with business needs and
how this addresses the cloud service
definitely we're exploding in the cloud
industry when it comes to data and
processing data if you do not know
Manuel Lloyd Manuel is a certified
process expert in operational efficiency
for healthcare IT as a virtual CI CIO or
virtual si ISO to medical practices all
teams report to manual as administers
directors insures maintains and is
responsible for all healthcare IT
operations efficiency manual honed his
skills directly for for President Ronald
Reagan at Camp David he turned his
knowledge into a business and created a
formula for evangelizing operational
efficiency Manuel has a number of
publications he's helped author
including PC Magazine a windfall for
outsourcing i.d IT LAN customers
increased profit in the book Poor
Richard's which addresses multiple
offices I think he needed after me
networking alternatives and
telecommuters through a little humor in
there sorry about that
for those who aren't familiar with this
form of webinar I want to introduce you
to your dashboard
if everyone can locate your dashboard
and then locate the question module if
it's auto amigo and click on the red
arrow and then find the question module
and if you can go ahead and just type in
hello or hi let's Manuel know that
you're excited to be here also lets us
know that our
system is working so if you can just go
ahead and type in hello or hi in the
question module there this is also your
best friend during the webinar if you
have questions that come up you can go
ahead and post them in here
we will save most of them till the very
end during the 15 minutes we'll try to
cover as many as we can
great to have you Christian sharam you
know a lot of people coming in excited
to have everybody here these are always
fun
I mean you always have like a really big
crowd that comes in so we have a lot of
great questions
Harvey glad to have you at the end we do
have the 15-minute question answers is
talking about so we'll save most of
questions for the end and I'll try to
filter through them some of them might
come up during the thing I'll leave that
up to Manuel if he sees them and wants
to pull them or not but I want him to
focus on doing the webinar and then
we'll do the QAS
if you hear something awesome brilliant
interesting insightful and you want to
share it in your social channels
whatever your social channels are
Facebook Linkedin tweet you can use the
hashtag SL webinars that way people can
find it and you'll make them wish they
were here with us if you didn't come
here to listen to me I am proud to
introduce Manuel who will be your host
for our lightning Idol service
continuity with cloud computing five
keys to success go ahead and sit back
relax have a cup of coffee tea or if
it's evening where you were at maybe a
glass of wine and enjoy it's an honor
for me to hand this over to Manuel thank
you and happy learning hello Manuel and
welcome to simply learn today
hello Richard how are you today I am
doing excellent and yourself I'm doing
well and I'm looking forward to this
webinar and I thank you so much for that
wonderful introduction and I think
everyone who's on the call for coming
and taking time out of your busy day to
come and listen to little old me I'll
tell you what thank you Richard
working with simply learned has been a
joy for me they have a wonderful program
I've taken some of the courses myself
and I just got to tell you what I'm
going to be talking about today
obviously if you already have ITIL
experience
you're gonna know what I'm talking about
but it's never you know you can never
know too much and we can all learn from
each other and if you have not taken an
opportunity to try one of the courses I
highly recommend I've been through I
can't even tell you how many training
courses and there's only two
organizations I won't mention the other
one there's only two organizations I've
ever gotten this kind of great training
that actually seems like hands-on and
ITIL is one of them and they're in a
more position for me right now so let's
get into it okay shall we alright so
let's go to our first slide most you
probably know what ITIL is and it's not
I just have this slide here and I'll
just read through it really quickly ITIL
is a framework for doing best practices
for IT and in a nutshell you know I put
cloud computing up here but in a
nutshell what you have to think about is
doing what works and getting it done
quickly ITIL is more of a set of books
for best practices but the biggest thing
about ITIL to remember as a practitioner
is that your job is to align the IT with
the business objectives and not the
business objectives with the IT a lot of
IT people make that mistake with CIOs IT
departments they make the mistake of
trying to align the business with the IT
and you really should align the IT with
the business and ITIL is perfect for
that and as Richard stated you know
cloud computing is something that you
know we call it cloud computing but most
of us know that it's just the internet
hosting right where someone's equipment
you're just hosting your dick on
someone's equipment in another location
the beauty behind cloud computing
organizations so especially the large
ones like Microsoft and Amazon cuz they
have high military grade security barbed
wire fencing underground reactions
repositories fail or
of the yin-yang if you will retina scans
and fingerprints ants and all kind of
protocols that a lot of people just have
here here's our data center or here's
our closet or here's our server room and
anybody and everybody can get in them
everybody is a domain admin the CIO this
the chief level executives want to be
the you know the main admins group so
it's just not as sophisticated and one
of the things you know the Richard
mentioned healthcare but one of the
things that and I have to change my bio
because I also help banks and any other
highly regulated industry because we're
moving toward a phase of infrastructure
being phased out of your your local area
right and Darrell these new appliances
coming through where you're basically
replicating your data in case of an
emergency and one of the things I tell
service continuity management helps you
do is to have a plan and a structure I
have a design and and and and and a
process for being able to maneuver your
data at will versus it being this big
big task and this big mystery about what
are you gonna do what you did and how
fast can you get it done and today's day
of microwave desires I would need it now
I want it now I've gotta have it now
it's too slow can we make it faster ITIL
plus cloud computing is going to help
you get to that point so you know what
is IT Service continuity management okay
it's it's the process of managing the
risk that could seriously affect your IT
now it's not just disaster recovery
either a lot of people make that mistake
there without IT service continuity man
it's just that disaster recovery right
knows a lot more than that remember ITIL
is a framework by which you should model
at least I think you should model Co
there's other frameworks out there but
this is the most successful one that
I've seen and I've been doing this for
30 years
a framework by which you have best
practices and activities that provide a
continuous service improvement
environment and so we're gonna go
through this charm a little bit later
cuz this right here over here on the
side here is talking about you know the
life cycle approach you know version 2
of ITIL if you will was more about
aligning the IT with the business well
and that's still good but version 3 of
ITIL talks about the lifecycle approach
which is going to be even better because
it makes a big deal about the continuous
service improvement the seven steps are
the continual service improvement and
this is something that if you have not
already done it yet you should at least
attempt to take a trial of the the ITIL
training with simply learn now in the
interest of full disclosure I'm your
course advisor as well so if you have
any questions you can always reach out
to the community and I can answer your
questions for any of the ITIL activities
now the biggest thing about the ITIL
training is that if you're using it in a
live environment I do that every single
day with hundreds and hundreds of of
different businesses that from large
fortune 500 to small one practice back
their offices it works for any size so
then we're also going to talk about ITIL
IT service continuity plan you know how
it goes along with your BCP or your
business continuity planning and
business continuity management all
together
alright one's car computing everybody
thinks they know what calm computing is
I think I know we all you know all of us
smart IT people right we know everything
right well cloud computing honestly NIST
has a definition for it and it's just
seeing as it's not even a new technology
it's just a new delivery right IT
service delivery IT service support and
cloud computing it's just a new delivery
and the beauty behind cloud computing in
IT service continuity management working
in conjunction is that you can move
faster now you know I have something and
you
my webinars before I talk about the
flash test Fla SH the flash test and
that test for me is it's got to be fast
it's got to be lean it's got to be agile
it's got to be secure and it's got to be
hassle and headache free right and
hacker free baby hassle headache and hat
hacker free right it's what you want to
get to so having cloud computing working
in conjunction with IT service
continuity management in the ITIL model
it's going to give you those those
things it's going to be fast because
you're gonna be able to maneuver your
data in a safe environment
you're gonna be able to have a test
environment we can try things out what
I'll have to do in an impact on the
entire business because when you go to a
c-level executive and you tell them hey
look we need to do a test of our
business continuity they're gonna go
well we don't want to shut down
especially hospitals especially these 24
hour organizations having a cloud
environment to me to duplicate or
replicate your environment to the tee
and fail it over to see how it works is
such a great thing and you say yeah well
I can do that in my own environment
where you gonna spend more money on
licenses it's just a whole big mess and
the whole goal for a c-level executive
is get it done as fast as possible the
best way possible I don't care and us
geeky people we want to do a certain way
we want to have control well you can't
have control with that cloud computing
in and today I'm going to in this
webinar I'm going to show you an example
from Microsoft and their of disaster
recovery for their cloud so what is the
disaster everybody thinks of disaster is
a natural disaster like a hurricane or
something but do you know that
hurricanes like I live in North Carolina
and we just had hurricane Matthew and
the biggest failure was not the weather
the biggest failure was electronic
failure okay with hospitals the biggest
disaster that's happening now ransomware
is targeting 88 percent of hospitals now
you call it a pH on the electronic the
Eph I data it's more valuable so don't
just think as a disaster of a natural
like a hurricane or flood or or an act
of God if you will people are the number
one reason okay and at about the number
two reason I believe is still in the
electronic but you know you do have
natural disaster you have accidental
hazards you got you know terrorism you
got internal employees who are malicious
when you do something to them or you
fire them and they have the right
credentials the keys of the kingdom
that's a whole nother webinar in itself
is how to manage the internal side of
continuity management now that'll be
another webinar we could probably do you
know Lawson or the structure the Bible
records lack of critical resources all
of those things are disasters within a
business you know you see on in the news
and on TV these major first it was the
banks right well of course it was the
online people like well actually it was
the credit card company and then it was
the online warehousing like Amazon and
eBay and then it became the banks now
it's the hospitals and I predict the
next wave of attacks is going to be to
the individual because it'll have a far
greater impact and fear for terrorists
who want to enact terror the problem is
most organizations are ill-equipped to
quickly respond to as Astrid so you have
your environment you have your topology
right you have your you have your your
ISP and you may have dual ISPs for
failover redundancy using protocols like
HS R P or whatever you want to use to
failover from one firewall to another or
one building to another whatever case
may be but a problem is with that then a
lot of costs associated with having a
secondary site or even secondary
equipment n plus one right so how do you
overcome that objection because your
goal as the as the practitioner or the
geek if you will is to identify and tell
your business side your c-level folks in
their terms that they can understand how
the problem in most enterprises is that
the the technical people don't
understand the business people and the
business people
understand the technical people so you
need an interpreter right or some kind
of interpreting methodology and that's
that's the problem that you run into
because the the business people said hey
you know with technology today there's
no way we have to spend a million
dollars on all of this infrastructure
doing and Makiki people to take well
yeah we gotta have it cuz I want to have
control of and I want to make sure I can
touch it whatever I'm telling you you're
not gonna win that battle if you're
trying to battle that with a c-level
executive your best battle is to say hey
we can actually take our cost center the
technology department data center it's a
call center and turn it into a profit
Center and be more profitable by cutting
cost and moving this thing into the
cloud especially the disaster recovery
piece of it the solution in my opinion
if ITIL ITSM or IT Service Management
and cloud computing and if you're not
familiar with either of these terms
obviously most people are for me with
cloud computing and when Richard comes
back all he can verify this but I think
simply Maron is starting to even do
cloud training like Microsoft has there
for instance training how to utilize it
in your environment and if you match
that up with some training with ITIL
you're going to be a superhero in your
business I can guarantee you that so the
goal is operational efficiency and
effectiveness right our goal is to be as
effective and efficient as we can and
having an infrastructure in your
building with multiple IT people
multiple business analysts multiple
developers right wasting time that's
let's just get right down to a wasting
time waiting on the IT to do its thing
because I tell people never can ever
finish a whole bunch of projects at once
there's always something going now the
misnomer is that what if I do this I'm
gonna lose my job i I do operational
efficiency for a lot of organizations
and that's always the thought when I
come in it's not you're here to help
you're here to take away my job and
that's not the case plus if you say that
that's just a self-fulfilling prophecy
anyway
I usually end up having the IT people
look like superheroes because they saved
a couple of money right and they cost
justify it by using the principles of
ITIL that's why it's so important to get
you if you're not certified or trained
get some training on that and and costs
justified so therefore you've taken the
language of the technigeek
and the technical geek to the business
kid right so now you're interpreting
that data to say here's why we did what
we did is our business case there's a
purpose and scope here to go here's what
we did here's the money that we save
here's the efficiency and effectiveness
that we're enabling now so that ITSM
Plus cloud computing equals operational
efficiency and effectiveness and I'm
gonna try to briefly show you how and we
may need to get into some more detail
here but if you look here on the left
this slide here talks about the business
continuity lifecycle you know I've
actually service man IT continuity
management service continuity management
you have your business continuity
management you have jockey ASM and the
way they line up here is BCM or business
continuity management and IT information
IT service continuity management you
have these category I won't go through
all of this but you have to business
continuity strategy versus over here you
have a requirement strategy and of
course I know it is based on a strategy
right starts with strategy and
everything's around the strategy the
design the trans operation the
transition to continue service
improvement
you have your business continuity plan
you have your reputation here the
ongoing operation on your operation
unification and continuity that so we're
going to get into that so I want to get
going here because I'm already it's
almost
I'm running out of time seems like
already hopefully I can go as long as I
need to
so I just went over this a little bit
and I think these slides will be
available to you
I'll check where Richard at the end of
the at the end of the call here so you
can review these in detail so I won't go
over all of these things right here
there are different cloud computing
models right typically there's you know
your internal
I'm a cloud a public cloud or an hybrid
when you use both I always like the
hybrid cloud I always like the hybrid
cloud and here's why you get the best of
both worlds and for those people who
like to quote unquote touch their city
their data you get to do that you have
control of your data at all times
there's just a sync copy somewhere else
and depending upon the strategy that you
choose in other words if you choose a
cold strategy or a warm strategy or a
hot strategy or do-nothing strategy
which I don't know who does that kind of
strategy but a cold strategy though is
for those folks who are going to say
look we can do without this data for 72
hours warm people are gonna say well we
gotta have it in 48 hours and the hot
people are saying we got to have it
pretty much now within 24 hours
hopefully in 15 minutes you know but
coal costs less warm cost a little bit
more and hot is very expensive so it
depends on what kind of strategy that
you want you know you got your native
private your low touch hybrid medium
touch hybrid high touch hybrid and
native touch hybrid but again the goal
is organizational resiliency how do I
get the vertical business objectives how
do I get the horizontal business
objectives aligned with the vertical
business units right so you have your
horizontal business objectives and all
the vertical business units they have to
do activities that align with that
horizontal vertical a horizontal
objective right so those are business
objective that's where we go back to you
talking about how the IT needs to align
itself with the business objectives and
not the business objectives aligning
with the IT that is a mistake that will
get you in a lot of trouble
and cost dirty processes and you'll
always be fighting fires forever so
specifically we're talking about
business continuity miseries not
resumption and disaster recovery you
know you have to have some
ship you hit from the top senior
management has to be involved and if you
don't have senior management involved
when you're doing this it's going to be
a disaster in itself so what does a
disaster look like and as a disaster
recovery process look like here we have
the first thing to happen is beginning a
disaster alert notification okay so and
you see the cut recovery point objective
here believe it or not most
organizations the c-level executives
that I'm looking for their tolerance
level is only about 15 minutes if you
talk to them and you do a business
impact analysis a BIA when you talk to
them and you know you go through all the
departments all the business units may
go well here's what I want when you get
back to the c-level executive they're
saying man we can't be down for that
long we we got to have this thing back
up in 15 minutes can we do that
and there's companies now building
infrastructure to work on that you know
IBM is working on infrastructure
Microsoft is Amazon is this is a little
company named empress kill they actually
have an appliance that will do it and
they're guaranteeing push-button
failover you know so there's a lot of
company building toward that fact and
Gartner's Gartner group is keeping track
of these companies and their quadrant to
see to tell you how well then they can
do it then one company I just mentioned
and for skill they were recently named
the cool Gartner cool product and which
is great for them because now they're
seeing animagic quadrant with these
larger organizations with an appliance
that actually can do this and I've
actually seen it works that's pretty
good then you have so your disaster
alert notification if you have a company
that is a secondary place like a peak
teen or course v60 or or a SunGard or
whatever the case may be you know you
notify them hey we think we have a
problem so we're putting you on notice
we'll put you on alert
typically and this is a textbook right
this doesn't happen like this exactly on
paper this is kind of like textbook so
about 1/2 hour one to two hour gap
between the next stage which is a damage
assessment so you get your teams
as management team recovery teams
infrastructure teams facilities teams
and get them all together in a room at
your command sir hey guys you know what
are we seeing here we here's our here's
my damage assessment here's my damage
assess if you're doing this on premise
then this is a this is going to take
that kind of time if you're using an IT
service continuity model this is going
to be more manageable but when you add
cloud to it it's going to be 10,000
times faster because hopefully you set
your cloud environment up with a test
environment or fell over environment
enough that you basically can push a
button if you will to start your
recovery process if you're doing this on
premise though you're going to run into
a lot of time and probably a lot of
problems a lot of people frustrated
they're going to be asking the IT
department when is the system gonna be
back up when does the system will be
back up what are we gonna be back up
where we go they're gonna ask you every
five minutes when is gonna mean you can
tell them every five minutes I don't
know we're working on it I don't know we
have a plane they're not gonna listen to
you so they're gonna want to see a
seamless failover which we all know
that's kind of difficult but it is
possible
whoops I went too far sorry about that
okay
so the next stage is a disaster
declaration assessment of disasters
declare you notify your your vendor hey
we're declaring a disaster and
unfortunately if you're doing this on
your own if you have a vendor that
doesn't have some kind of cloud platform
this disaster is gonna be down here at
the bottom here we're talking about the
maximum tolerable outage you have to
take the amount of money per hour that
an organization is losing when they're
down neck and range anywhere from five
thousand dollars or a small business per
hour to 600,000 to a million dollars per
hour for a larger business that's a lot
of dough right and then when the
disasters clerk reclaimed you go into
your you know your recovery time
objectives and the resumption of
services but that bottom line down here
this maximum tolerable outage
is shrunk significantly when you use IT
service continuity management model and
your BCM or your business continuity
management along with cloud computing
it's shrunk significantly so think about
that and I know some of you probably
already know this but I'm gonna read
this to you real quick you know and it
kind of in my terms and that's
misspelled no it didn't okay so RPO r ta
MTO so there so our PR recovery point
objective is the maximum time amount of
end time of data that can be lost in
case of a disruption you know that's the
answer the question to what point in
time can I recover that's going to be
the first thing your bosses your c-level
executives are gonna want to know and
you look at the Loews chart over here on
the right is talking about RPO and RTO
the next one is going to be the maximum
amount of time it will take from
disruption to bringing back the business
functions according to the agreements
included including data so this is
obviously something that you need a
business continuity plan right hopefully
you've done a business impact analysis
of the threat and risk assessment all
the things you need to do that come
inside of a business continuity plan and
this is the recovery time objective okay
and if you look here it's the simplest
way to explain this to a non-technical
person is Rp owes to complete the
completed business transaction loss in
an RTO is the new business opportunities
lost okay
then you have your maximum tolerable
outage or nao it's the time frame during
which a recovery must become effective
before now how does compromises the
ability of an organization to achieve
its business objectives okay and again
this all comes with a lot of planning
you know how do you establish your RPL
and your RTI into you in the cloud so
there's two ways to do it in the cloud
you can do it have a secondary site
excuse me and you still good you're
better than having it on-site so onto
the site you can do it that way here's
some of the pros and cons of that so
from a regular cloud backup solution you
can restore
from a previous backup start with the
most you know recent backup make sure to
scan from viruses all that good jazz you
know one of the things about scanning
viruses is and backing up is just one
little caveat that you guys probably
know this is one of the mistakes I've
seen when people are doing their
business continuity is that their backup
windows interfere with their business
continuity plans because they're doing
backups and virus scans and malware
scans at the same time so those files
are never really truly backed up
properly so you have to kind of stage
them but you guys probably know that so
you want to if the files and folders
contain a virus you know go go to the
previous version once clean version has
found restore the files a folder and
this is good you know a good backup is
it's a good way to fight ransomware
obviously right pros of that is that as
I deal with individual files or folders
when they're infected the problem that
you run into though is you need to scan
individual files and copy folders until
you find a clean copy which is going to
take a lot of time or it's ineffective
if the entire service it affected and
you don't have a bare metal backup kind
of a situation like a shadow copy or
shadow protect I forget what the name of
the product is but anyway this is a
typical cloud backup solution and people
will go to their boss and say yeah we
have business continuity and no you know
you don't really have business
continuity that's just a backup one of
the things that a lot of companies are
offering now you'll see this is dress or
disaster recovery as a service you know
the beauty behind disaster recovery has
a service in the cloud especially now
you can do this on your homes apprentice
it's just it just brings a higher risk
but if you're do it in a cloud you can
smell it the vm's with the most recent
image you can log into booted images to
verify it doesn't contain a virus but
the virus is found you can login to the
next most recent image now if you're
doing snapshots or whatever the case may
be so the pros of the two different ways
of just a cloud-based vanilla backup
versus a disaster recovery as a service
as I'm going to get into
here it's much faster to inspect the
whole system is intact users can access
applications immediately which is gonna
make all of the c-level people happy
because now they're making money you can
it keeps VM self-contained
so it can't affect the other hands
problem is you gotta have a draft
solution that can boot on a local
appliance because if you're trying to
everything out of the cloud is just
going to be slow as molasses and that's
going to increase your connectivity cost
for the for your internet so you have
some kind of appliance that's that I've
mentioned earlier in this conversation
that can boot to VM mucho VM that are
replicated and been replicated you know
24 hours a day and you pick you do your
criticality analysis of your
applications and you tear them out tear
0 to 1 to 2 I wouldn't go any more than
tier 3 some people go more than those
tiers lower than organizations like I
just did a speech for Duke they say they
do you know like eight tiers or
something like that so that's that's
that's pretty deep
so let's go and talk about the Klingon
sorry with all the things I just said
there you have to have a plan right so
I'm gonna go through this quickly
because this is not what his webinars
about so a business continuity plan
looks like this you have a commencement
you commit up a BIA or business impact
analysis a threat and risk assessment
you develop response strategy those in a
khole warm/hot strategies you develop
the continuity plans for the chosen
strategy you know how you gonna do it
exercise plans tabletop exercises fell
or tests in the cloud not on Prem some
people do it on Prem they actually fill
over there their real live environment
which is really risky especially if you
don't have a duplicate environment not a
duplicate copy of the data by the
duplicate environment and then audit and
plans and of course you're doing this
continuously in a continuous service
proven model so let's talk a real bit
about a real live disaster recovery as a
service cloud Microsoft has a cloud
solution called a sir alright and and
Richard could correct me when he comes
back on I think simply Ron provides
training for answer
so Microsoft's cloud solution has a
breadth and depth for business
continuity disaster recovery in the
cloud I mean super fast so I'm just
gonna not go through all of these things
one by one cuz you'll get these slides
but I just want to kind of show you what
it looks like from a high-level overview
so you have your hyper-v fell over by
the way this works with VMware that you
should not work with VMware and I
believe they're working with me and
we're now where if you use the Microsoft
cloud I believe you had to convert your
VMware to hyper-v and I think they've
resolved that now but you might want to
check with your Microsoft we're have to
validate that or maybe the training I
haven't taken the simpler answering on
it yet but I'm quite sure they cover
that so they're my Microsoft calls there
as their site recovery and I think that
amazon has something with a similar name
so it's one solution for multiple
infrastructures right replication you
have your hyper-v or your your
hypervisor you know from on-premise to
their cloud okay
you can do your sand hyper-v into
Microsoft Azure but there's several ways
to do this and again you're putting ITSM
or information technology continuity
served service continuity management
into the cloud ok so here are some more
slides about the way it works you can
orchestrate protection and recovery of
private clouds you can do a site-to-site
either on-premise that as a protection
so your site to answer they just came
out with this and october 2014
that's the way it was in 2014 but in
december 2014 you can new customer to
has ur SMB the hazard and that's that's
so anyway so adler sought recovery
service you know you have automated
protection you have continuous health
monitoring orchestrated recovery and i'm
trying to go through these slides a
little faster so I can get enough time
for questions here's how it works so you
have you here right
you actually sign up for a 30-day cut I
think it's a 30-day free trial or
something like that and you configure
your your site you create a a recovery
plan what I was talking about you start
doing some health monitoring of your
servers right you orchestrate the
recovery of services in the event of an
outage okay so let me go back here I'm
rolling through these kind of quick so I
apologize so you create a vault you you
you can do two step-by-step guidance and
then the six steps and I don't want to
I'm not trying to sell Microsoft here so
I'm gonna move on for that you don't see
these any slides if you get them from
simply my Microsoft gives you flexible
options not just Microsoft but Amazon
does as well
the difference to know between Amazon
and Microsoft that I I've noticed is
that Amazon charge you like point zero
zero zero three cents or something like
that depending on how much of data that
you buy from them and what kind of deal
you make whereas Microsoft says hey you
can load all you want now you pay five
or ten dollars per VM or whatever it is
load all the data you want we're not
gonna charge your dime no worries have a
big party however when you need your
data they're gonna make you pay you're
gonna pay egress right so that's why the
planning is so important and training
and educating yourself about how as it
works about how ITSM works is so crucial
so you have a grasp and a knowledge pane
excuse me and a command of information
technologies service continuity
management business continuity
management and if you're gonna use azor
azor and I've known that simply learn
has training for all of those okay when
do you need to choose as or any other
cloud provider you know if you have a
secondary site available you use a
system center virtual machine manager
you have currently unprotected workloads
you could benefit from reducing the
impact of playing downtime on your
primary data center which is what I was
telling you before is that if you have a
test now I always try to put things in
five environments to keep things smooth
excuse me when I'm consulting with my
clients you know you have your live
environment which is heaven if you will
you have your backup environment you
have your excuse me your lot of mom is
also your storage environment your life
saying you know whatever you use you
have your backup environment archive
environment for a lot of highly
regulated industries like healthcare and
making you have to have that data
archive you have your disaster recovery
environment and you have your testimony
so does that the disaster recovery
environment in a test environment look
just alike but the disaster recovery
environment is the live environment for
the test environment or in the live
environment replicated for the live
environment and hopefully I didn't
confuse you on that but basically if you
take number one which is your live
environment and number four which is a
disaster recovery about it they should
look exactly alike at me replicated the
beauty behind having the dr in the cloud
is that you can play with it if you will
and when you do a failover test you do
it through the dr environment you don't
do it to the live environment but
because of the our environment looked
exactly to the second or whatever your
window is that depends on your strategy
you choose hot warm or cold it provides
you such great flexibility and power to
knew exactly what's going to happen now
the test environment is your sandbox you
play with it you you say here's what I
want to do all right that didn't work
that didn't work now let's try this
using the ITSM model you can go through
those stages of the lifecycle of ITSM
and test each one of those stages to
ensure that you have a resilient
organization and then and some of these
cloud computing environments you can
actually apply that to your live in Arma
so once you've tested it once you've
proven in that it's right you can
actually bridge that over to your live
environment any changes that you need to
make sure that your dr
it's bulletproof and this is what I was
talking about with the downtime
virtually every business will experience
some downtime
you know 91% according to forget who I
got this - I don't know if it's a Pew
study or IDC study but I think it's on
the next slide now the one percent of
those surveyed have had some adenosine
outage in the past 24 months 47 percent
of companies experience in our downtown
this year they will experience that and
there we go hardware failure is the
number one reason you see where natural
disasters it's 5% heart worth a human
error software fare that those are big
or downtime machine so you can't sit
there and depend on looking at the
weather and then deciding you're gonna
go ahead and do your continuity plan IT
service continuity management prepares
you to being a continuous serve
improvement environment throughout the
lifecycle of your entire resiliency of
your business and you know I was wrong I
said $5,000 so this study here shows
that it's more like $8,000 for a small
company in 600,000 for large companies
per hour of downtown that's a lot of
money you know an eight-hour workday you
know what's that 4.8 million dollars for
the large companies and six six hundred
thousand dollars for the Lord for the
small companies that will put them out
of business a small company it will put
them out of business and what it would
cause a lot of pain and heartache for
the larger businesses and if their Wall
Street based base to businesses it's
gonna hurt their numbers on Wall Street
in their stock a lot of barriers to to
the on-demand failover the other dress
the disaster recovery servers in the
cloud too expensive they say some say
33% says too expensive
excuse me some kind of nasty bug going
around here so I apologize holic often
25 cents they have any any fishing
resources 22% says to
sooo complex and there's too many
compatibility issues well that's getting
better so you need to have a very wise
conversation with your entire IT team
and your senior leadership about what
products services to get but the beauty
behind IT service continuity management
is that it is agnostic it doesn't care
of which product or which hardware or
software you get those principles are
going to help you pick the right product
and service in the first place based
upon the learning that you received from
the IT service continuity management
from a company like simply learn and
trust me I know that the product that
training product is after it and very
very good and and and it's just gonna
make you a superstar in your
organization there's a source actual
tech media is where I've got I pull the
source from so the trade-offs aren't the
traditional trade-offs is you know
off-site tape backup yeah people still
use that believe it or not problem is
trying to find a little ta tapes okay
cloud backup what we mentioned applies
backup you know that's pretty good okay
we're getting better here but look and
see how the costs are going up though
when you when you pick these different
new technologies Kol site dr i mentioned
that that's a strategy war on site dr is
cost more hot site is just gonna go
through the roof we want dr as a service
nirvana we want to be right here how do
we get everything we need at a low low
expensive cost well you're not gonna
know that if you don't know the
principles of business continuity
management and you're not gonna know the
principle of business continuity
management if you don't know the
principles and the life cycle of IT
service continuity management so i
highly motivate you to take some
training on that if you had not already
and guess what I look at my training
over and over and over and over again
every time I go into a situation I pull
out my simply learned training like ok
but ok yeah that's ok I remember that
make my little notes and it's really
cool so Cobb NCR should be on the man so
your end users oh there's a server
and applications are down hey where's
the net we're gonna be back up hey what
is it server go to me go you hit it
every five minutes so you haven't ever
done anything all right Superman right
then you say okay well but the users can
continue to work with recovered apps
virtualized from the appliance or within
the cloud if you have this model okay
so users are still working and your
downtime is minimum remember I told you
that the appetite for this is 15 minutes
or less that's that's the that's the
tolerance that people are getting to
want to me at and their company's making
products for that 15 minutes or less so
in order to do that we're talking about
the five principal right these are the
five must-haves that you must have in
order to have a successful information
technologies service continuity
management plus cloud computing model
number one you don't need to break the
bank okay there are products out there
that just because they're a big company
they feel like they can sell you a big
price don't be fooled by that do your
research
once again to Harper on IT service
continuity management you're gonna learn
those principles on what to pick and why
you know use cloud x4 clouds spill over
exploit
export comes spill over you know exploit
that use that to your advantage
get complete coverage number one because
that's what the your are number three
that's what you're seeing it almost no
know what find something that's like a
push-button failover that company that
I've mentioned to you earlier in for
skill they claim that and I've seen it
work actually you know I don't I don't
think you can work in a super large
environment but it may I think there may
be 100 VMs or maybe a couple of hundred
VMs because it's not I don't think will
admit to be and and I think they're
working on a larger scale but hey if you
have something like that you should look
them up their name is infra scale in
frost gale and of course you want to
encrypt your data so breaking to make
let's not break the bank let's not get
unit we don't need something that's too
explicit to implement too complex to use
one of the RPO in RT o trade-offs that
goes with that planning business
continuity plan
okay how are you vulnerable to hackers
by choosing something that's not gonna
work for you yeah you know I've actually
had a hospital asked me about using a
Carbonite and no lab they really asked
me about using Carbonite for their
hospital and I actually laughed and told
him I'm not the right guy to help him
that they won't he's Carbonite for that
not saying copyrights not a good product
that's not for a hospital that's a real
story you want to exploit the cloud
spill over most base equals more
appliances in your arm premise network
using the IT Service Management in the
cloud there's going to be more spacing
to the more cloud right well what's this
going to be more expensive so you have
one that's an effects model ones that
look that's a capex model or you can
have a hybrid of capex Plus objects you
want to keep the cost down and and the
whole IT ITIL a whole process of ideal
which is a strategy designed transition
op op transition operations into service
improvement it's going to help you with
some financial management to be able to
balance that capex versus effects versus
a hybrid of capex and OPEX we talked
about getting complete coverage you need
to be able to back up any device any be
supporting any OS need to be able to
deploy in any form need to be stored any
cloud it doesn't matter you need to be
able to recover anything you shouldn't
matter you you know you can you should
be able to boot
anywhere and you should be able to fail
back any system this is very expensive
on-premise but in the cloud with when a
hybrid like an appliance plus the cloud
IT service continuity management Plus
cloud it's going to save your company
thousand millions and hundreds of
millions of dollars depending upon how
big your organization is and this is why
it's so important to if you don't know
number one if you don't know about using
this strategy we are going to a cloud
first strategy mobile first strategy
moving forward NIT having ITIL on your
side and the cloud on your side working
in conjunction with you you're going to
be a superstar
I've talked about that push-button
failover
it's got to support all the environments
it's happy
it hasn't be able to boot anywhere and
it's got to be wickedly fast and I'm
speeding up a little bit here
talk about encryption your data you know
one of the things that I like about the
encryption of the data is nowadays you
could do double triple blind encryption
and have like an encryption key kind of
like a rest where attacker they said
then you have this encryption key
obviously that needs to go to like an
attorney or a c-level executive and put
on a lock and safe well then they can
get it out and not some disgruntled
employee who's going to run away with it
and thus become a ransomware attacker
so encryption is important but none of
this means anything to you and I've been
doing this for thirty years and I still
train I stand I rinse and I repeat
because knowledge is power you know plan
new plan act check new plan act check -
that is my presentation I hope you've
enjoyed it I am now Richard gonna open
it up for questions and let you take
over
excellent Thank You Manuel great session
grab yourself a drink of water I
understand how that goes and gets a
little drag doing these sessions so
we're gonna start with a couple things
I'll take over just for a couple minutes
here one I have to take over the screen
and then we're going to pull at the end
so they'll have a poll come up on their
screen you're not going to see it as far
as a little questionnaire take the time
to go ahead and fill that up and I'll
probably have that fill that out and I
will have that up for just about 5-10
minutes one of the questions it comes in
is will we be able to go back and look
at this session or is it recorded the
answer is yes if you want to get a copy
of this session it does take up to 12
hours for them to double check it you go
to simply learn comm click on support
and just let them know hey I was at this
webinar can you send me a copy and
they'll send you a link for that so that
is being recorded on here now been well
brought up a lot of
notes on certifications simply learn
itself so I'll go ahead and take that
question - before I start passing them
back to back over
We certainly have on our courses if you
would assembly learn comm you can click
on all courses and under technology
you'll see there is under cloud
computing they have AWS a number of
different options in there like a
technical essentials developer associate
sis ops associate solutions architecture
associate it definitely gets broken up
depending on what your specialty is and
what you're looking for
they also have the Microsoft Azure
development solution architect in there
and solutions there's a number of those
depending again which are going to and
also the Google cloud platform so we
offer certification all those there's
even a docker class and if you ever
played with docker but it's kind of a
fun one too and then under the IT we
have the different ITIL foundation the
very basic ones and then intermediate
and CSIS OOS a PPO all the different
ones in there to help you get certified
and to maximize your career potential so
the number of questions coming in here
let me go and ask this one of Manuel
well we're wait well we're doing the
poll could you talk a little bit between
the difference between ITIL and ITSM
seems this is ITSM there's a question
concerning that as far as like the title
of the the webinar well I assume his IT
Service Management and ITIL is like
information technology infrastructure
library there pretty much am I paying
the same when you look at it IT Service
Management 90 service delivery
pretty much come from the version 2 or
version 2011 I believe it was or 2007 of
ITIL I am I am a certified I tell person
and ITSM and I TSD are things that are a
part of the core principles of the
British standard
now being moved toward the ISO 20 I want
to say ISO 27000 which includes moral
risk management because the the problem
with it is that because technology
evolves so much and this British
standard is very old by the way this
very standard I think it was British
Standard 15,000 where I tell came out of
it's a very old standard but very
effective standing that has had stood
the test of time because of cloud
computing so many things are changing
because the risk management has to be
more involved and there's actually more
discussions and requests for comments
coming for how to do more with cloud
computing and mobile computing with
within a ITIL framework so I kind of say
60 one-half dozen the other there you
can look at the definitions and see some
of the frameworks but if you take an
ITIL Service if you take an ideal course
you're gonna be on version 3 I believe
that you guys train on Richard and it's
going to include some IT Service
Management training in that ok excellent
yeah I'm and I'm not an expert in ITIL
my path is very different actually work
with the programming and development
side but I love these webinars I'm
always learning something new and then
we had on PowerPoint someone asked for
the PowerPoint we don't actually send
out the PowerPoint but you can get a
copy of the actual session and I see
that Prashant what I'll do is I'll send
your email back to our support team or
you just go to simply learn dot-com and
request it that's all I'm gonna do and
then I had somebody who I'm not sure
what there but Rumsey is asking exat
I'm not sure what that stands for I see
I'm not sure ok so he added some more
stuff the background ITIL now has
upgraded to cloud fields that's also
from Ramsay I don't know if that makes
sense
I know cloud definitely the cloud is is
now
part of the ITIL package because you
know for a company and I work with
startups a lot of times you need an
affordable way to spin up your business
and that cloud is very central to that
and understanding how the ITIL works in
the background is also central to that
here's a question coming in from about
dunya I hope I said that right is there
a way to integrate service now with IP
SM and cloud computing does she mean
service now the the tool the software
tool I'm assuming I think service now
claims that they are ITIL based I would
check with your service now vendor to
see what templates and workflows that
you can place put in place to help you
with things like Service Desk it's an it
management you know configuration
management those things for your service
not tool that's what I'm assuming she's
talking about okay excellent
excellent we have coming in from another
question coming in here in dr when we
move from traditional tape backup
there's old-school I remember having to
do archive tapes too hot dr the cost and
time both increases what was showcased
during the which was showcased during
the presentation is that case in that
case what are the benefits of moving
from tape backup to hot dr what do you
get out of it that's a pretty extreme
jump from from tape backup to hot they
are but I have not seen tapes in large
environments be as successful as the
c-level executives want them to be I'm
not saying they're not successful but
they do take a lot of time and they're
very expensive to keep all of those
tapes in either a 12 week rotation or
whatever kind of rotation you have them
in
and they are not as reliable as discs so
if you're in a smaller garment and you
have tapes and you can stand that you
know great I just don't trust tapes I
have not I may I have clients like the
credit card company oh gosh I came
thinking her name right now the launch
equifax I believe it is they have some
tapes in different arenas and it just
depends on your environment you know
again that goes to the criticality
criticality analysis of your
applications
you know what tier do you want them in
if you want them to be in a 15 minute
window that's pretty much a media that's
a zero tier if they can take 72 hours
which is pretty much a called strategy
then takes maybe ok with you I just have
not run into any organizations that are
interested in being that slow to recover
from a disaster and that risky as well
excellent yeah that I'm not in your
particular feel but that sounds about
right to me from what my little
experience is let's see we got from
Romsey coming in I prepared my expert
ITIL certification for next month's my
question if the process and best
practices for IT al are up to date with
the cloud pre requirement my question if
the process and best practices are up to
date with the club pre requirement so I
guess he's asking if the ITIL practices
are currently up to date with the cloud
pre requirement I don't know if that if
you understand that question if we need
to get more information from wrong we
might need to get more information I
think Ramsey I understand what you're
saying are you asking if simply learns
course updated or or is the ITIL because
you know none of us can change the ITIL
version 3 standard it is what it is
right now but at the core if you talk
about the course
I think that the course that simply
learned offers well I know that the
course that's implemented offers is up
to date all the way through I believe up
to the cloud and and some of the other
standards that they're talking about and
if you have you've already if you're
preparing for your master I think you
said or you're doing malke
managing across the lifecycle that is
covered in there I believe someone from
sickling would have to validate that if
that's the your question if your
questions more about the actual standard
itself then we have you have to go to a
lexos website to actually get that
information okay excellent and you know
one of the new things we have is because
we have instructors like Manuel here we
get a lot of people who are in the field
in all of our courses and so you get
that direct input both on the forums and
in the classroom where they take it a
new level and there they let you know
hey this is what I'm actually using a
for this is what's going on in the field
which is one of the things I love that's
what I love about being in a classroom
is is you get that not only the hands-on
and the learning but you get some real
live feedback of what's going on there
hey thanks I was from Romsey okay thanks
so in that case cloud backup or
appliance backup is more suited and
recommended for a small organization
with a small amount of data yeah small
amount of data depending on what you're
saying a small amount of data is
typically you know you have places like
Amazon you know AWS you can do a small
amount anyone can do a small amount of
data a cloud backup is fine it depends
on if you're regulated if you're a
regulated industry for instance in
healthcare you have to have a a backup
Rakata backup plan a disaster recovery
plan emergency mode operation plan
application criticality analysis and
provisioning and also a evaluation of
your of your data so that's all going to
depend if you just want to backup your
data and have it off-site that's fine
but backing up your data is not a
disaster recovery plan backing up your
data is one piece one morning Green
to making a cake so if you think about
data the whole amount of data and stood
up in a VM or whatever the case may be
you think about the eggs the flour the
baking powder the yeast whatever you use
the frosting those are all the different
components to one cake your one cake is
your data if you only have one piece of
it you're not going to get the entire
part of the entire cake it's not it's
not gonna it's gonna leave a bad taste
in your mouth no point no pun intended
so that's a good analogy yeah I always
make my cakes without the sugar just I
could really no no no Chris my wife is
on a health kick so now we use all kinds
of strange ingredients in there but they
still tell about really good they have a
time for a couple more romney said by
the way great sir so i guess he
appreciates the feedback you're giving
which is always nice to hear can you
talk a little bit about the difference
between microsoft azure versus amazon or
the AWS cloud AWS cloud is the cadillac
the Mercedes the Bentley whatever car
you is your your top car Microsoft just
came into this game to try to do what
Amazon is doing and Amazon has a huge
market cap on the the cloud space the
biggest difference with Amazon and
Microsoft that I see is managing your
cost you have to be very careful with
Amazon because everything looks cheap
buy pennies less than pennies on the
dollar but it adds up when you talk
about bandwidth utilization and getting
your data and in the environment
protecting your data whereas Microsoft
their big thing is egress so Microsoft
is gonna charge you as you take your
data as it goes back to you when you do
a disaster recovery plan they can let
you put in as much as you want you pay
typically you pay you pay per VM or
something like that i think i think ii
just ten dollars but Microsoft also has
something
with an appliance that you can buy that
cheap that makes it a little bit cheaper
and they go on as their points or
something or another best thing to do is
to get a consult
you call reek down to me again I can get
you like a matrix of different pros and
cons of Microsoft versus the Amazon
versus of Google bruster the high VM
cloud there's a lot of cloud companies
out there that can do the same thing
it's just that Amazon is the Big Daddy
of a ball excellent yeah I've just
played with Emma or used Amazon just a
little bit or actually indirectly
through other companies so yeah there's
a lot of providers out there now it's a
big arena
let's see things are jumping in on my
screen hold on how the ITIL cloud
training and certification conducted by
simply learn is it theory based and
practical sessions comes from Kumar
that's a good question exactly how are
these classes set up these classes are
set up you can have instructor-led or
self-taught self led courses and they're
based upon the the Exynos best practice
guide directly from the books and they
give you exercises and exam for you to
test yourself to make sure you
understand as a matter of fact they have
a guarantee or not a guarantee but they
I think they promise that you'll pass
your exam on the first they have more
people passing the exams on the first
try let me let me not speak for for
simply learn but it's very easy read
they give you exam download where you
can follow along take notes if you do a
self-exam or even a instructor into him
where you can actually follow along you
get exercises and it's it's not theory
it's based upon the actual Excel owes IT
lifecycle I tell you life cycle it
depends on what you want to do there's
one course that does and
to prepare you for your managing across
life cycle so you can look to become an
expert and also up to becoming a master
ITIL excellent and continue along the
lines we have a couple other questions
on there that we do need to wrap it up
here soon
one of individuals is currently studying
for the ITIL foundations is there a
specific area they should pay close
attention to before the exam well the
biggest thing with ITIL is remembering
that the customer is first that the
business process think business process
and not technology think customer not
technology that's the biggest thing to
remember on taking those exams and
looking and looking at the material you
have to always think customer first if
you put on your paper when you take your
test customer first it will help you fly
through many of the questions but
they'll be very apparent to you what the
answers are
don't they take now first a customer
first excellent and I'm just going to
have one last question and if we weren't
able to get to some of your questions on
here or we didn't cover them as far as
you were looking for if you go to simply
learn comm and click on the community or
you can also go to community about
simply learn comm we have an open forum
in there
and we do go through there monitor those
forums and that post answers is a great
place to post answers if you're already
a member of simply learn there's also a
simply let talk for me a format you can
go into which is just specifically for
people in the classrooms so it's usually
more specific to simply learn so we have
both the community forum and then the
closed forum for people who are members
exactly yes we have we have wonderful
experts who come in there and then it's
really nice I like going through there
cuz I work with the big data and the
developers side and it's amazing how
much I learned by what questions are
asked you know I find myself sometimes
everyone's when I get stumped you know
but usually I just keep
the brain going and thinking about it
well how do you fix this how do you
figure that out those forums are really
powerful and great to jump on and you
it's ask your questions on there so one
last quick question on here or I'll
answer two of them where do you see
Oracle in this race particularly is very
costly database technology and are they
yet to enter the India market with the
same
what do you see Oracle going cuz I know
20 years ago it was huge yeah
Oracle certified DBA I don't really
practice much of it I just keep my
skills up but I see that there there
there five things that will never never
never ever go away in Oracle duties on
databases or one of those things but
you're going to have to have a server or
not have a database you're gonna have to
have end-user device you're going to
have to have networking so and you're
gonna have to have some kind of
telecommunications so I see Oracle
staying relevant now as far as where
they're going with you know hosting a
cloud or something like that I don't see
their name come up and a lot of a lot of
[Music]
conversations for that particular
instance but I can tell you that whoever
gets to be the Marvel of cloud storage
platforms platforms as a service they
will be the Big Cheese and that's why I
think Dell took the risk of buying EFC
and took that 40 billion dollar Delta to
go into debt to buy EMC because I think
Michael Dell probably sees that that's
the future I don't think that's a good
partnership pretty and particular but I
think that a lot of hardware vendors are
going to get with software vendors and
try to become a ma belle of of a data
center to be in the host platform as a
service because businesses are trying to
cut cost and have more real estate or in
their footprints in with
they're all facilities excellent with
that we do need to go ahead and wrap up
and I apologize again for anybody we
didn't get to again thank you man man
well I always enjoy your sessions I get
the joy of also chatting with Manuel
before the session so I get a little
extra information on there again the
PowerPoint we don't directly share the
PowerPoint as there's actually changing
and there stuff going on but you can
certainly go to simply learn comm and
request a copy of the session skill have
that the whole webinar recorded we do
record them all thank everybody for
being here and especially Thank You
Manuel for your time and taking time off
to join us today X and thanks to Rumsey
prashant christian we have a lot of
people thinking us at the end here
excellent it's just really excellent to
have everybody here these webinars are
really inspirational and a great source
of learning with that I'm gonna go and
close the webinar thank everybody for
being here look forward to seeing you in
our classrooms and wish you a wonderful
day evening afternoon or morning
depending on where you're at maybe
you're lucky and you're hanging out by
the beach and doing some nice weather
you